uh vaccine is looking very good for
pretty soon we'll be talking about that
a little bit later on
we're going to florida we're going to
north carolina we're doing a double stop
we'll be doing some triples along the
way but right now we're
sort of in the earlier stages the poll
numbers you saw were very good they're
really
getting good despite all of the
disinformation campaigns that the
democrats run
pure disinformation so we're doing very
well
we'll have a good trip today and i'll
see you during the trip any questions
mr president when you talk any money in
your opinion
yeah if i have to i would but we're
doing very well we needed to spend more
money up front
because of the pandemic and the
statements being made by democrats which
were again disinformation we've done a
great job with govit
we've done a great job with the china
virus a great job
whether it's ventilators or whether it's
vaccines which you'll be seeing very
soon
or therapeutics we've done a great job
but the press was
uh fake and we have to spend a lot of
money now if we need
if we did need we don't because we have
much more money than we had last time in
the
going into the last two months i think
double and triple
but if we need it anymore i put it up
personally like i did in the uh
primers last time in the 2016 primaries
i put up
a lot of money if i have to i'll do it
here but we don't have to because we
have
double and maybe even triple what we had
uh
a number of years ago four years ago
how much are you talking about whatever
it takes we have to win
this is the most important election in
the history of our country
we have a radical left group going
around these people there
there's something wrong with them there
really is there's something wrong with
them
and joe doesn't have the strength he
doesn't have the mental capability to
control these people
and you take a look at what's going on
and i looked at pittsburgh i looked at
rochester
i looked at l.a last night i looked at
these democrat-run cities
you look at portland every night they
don't have the strength they don't have
the
the i don't think the democrats have the
courage to control these people
they're afraid to even talk about law
and order they can't issue the words
law and order all we want is law and
order and i just put out something the
suburbs are coming big to us because
the suburbs are next if you elected
this guy the suburbs would be
overwhelmed
with violence and crime so that's where
we are
this is the most important election in
the history of our country
so that's it we'll see you in florida
thank you very much